rietschen new level domain name ist luca
und ich spiele heute mal wieder gold
teamleiter mit euch allerdings nicht in
der gleichen letztes mal sondern diesmal
gehen wir ingo zb das seht ihr schon das
ist eine etwas neuere map siege hast du
bock auf die ganze show aber zuerst muss
ich mal sagen es wurde mir extrem
die autos haben irgendwie was gegen mich
in diesem spiel also kommt mir sofort
ich habe ja in den kommentaren gefragt
ob irgendwelche namen für diese ziege
kennt und ganz über allen anderen
alles klar ziege der name mit den
meisten likes war kevin diese ziege
heißt jetzt kevin wie entstand das ganze
eigentlich mit kevin dieses kevin frank
annahme ist es einfach wegen kevin
allein zu haus oder ok alles klar was
ist das denn sehr sehr
sieger kevin herrmann wo bist du
weil das irgendwas von wegen aliens auch
sieger kevin vollidiot kevin termin und
die leiter laufen jetzt diese halfpipe
hoch gewinnen muss dann leider vergessen
wir auch du dummkopf termin ist einfach
der perfekte name für diese ziege die
ist einfach und übelster vol.at mit ich
bin unter dem ok ich hab' ich hoffe dass
kevin ständig an
das sieht irgendwie falsch aus was kevin
macht diese dummkopf ziege kann ich
nicht irgendwie auf diese halfpipe
darauf muss doch irgendwie einen weg
geben dass ich da irgendwie drauf jumpen
kann oder ist es da irgendwie nicht
ich habe darf ich mich du dir liegen
jetzt die hallo mein name ist kevin und
ich aus dem ei france mein name ist
kevin und ich hätte ganz gerne freunde
wollen uns alle zusammen was macht ihr
mit acht unterhalten sich ich habe mich
mit freunden ich habe heute so ein
toller keine sorge
haye will lasst uns als unternehmen
kommen wir gehen in diesem halfpipe ding
und du kommst mit beziehung zwischen
kevin und sein freund ist wie zwischen
mir und meinen freunden
man muss sie einfach an lecken und mit
wie was rede ich hier schon wiederkommen
will man wie immer wieder leben ein
abenteuer kommen wird will man will man
konnte die komik müllmann was ist denn
der hat sie so komme ich denn hier nicht
hoch kann ich nicht einfach mal hier
nicht irgendwie fallenlassen von schlitz
das hat gut geklappt sie sieht aus wie
eine halfpipe aber es funktioniert ja
nicht
danke ziegel ich habe heute einfach kein
skateboard aber ich schaue mal ob ich
hier mich runter
das hat unglaublich was ist das und ein
knopf
das ist nicht wahr we can you love me
later giraffe oder katze bitte noch mal
eben in motion machen wir diese giraffe
gefallen
oh mein gott schaut euch den arsch an um
das in zivilisten hallo alter was geht
bei dieser gira eigentlich bräuchten wir
für jedes du bist gerade nicht wirklich
über so einen scheiß straßenschild
gestolpert oder die rache als ob du über
ein
alles klar sonst geht es dir gut da
unten oder sieht nämlich nicht so
gesundheit wiederum leaks jo was macht
dieser typ da vorne hat er was macht
dieser typ
hier ist gerade irgendwo ein typ ins
wasser gegangen während ich hier weiter
mit meinem kader war ganz unglücklich
durch die weiten des meeres der flüssige
taucher würde ich sagen war es das mit
diesem teil juli eröffnete simulator
mittlerweile es gibt noch mehrere andere
formen also beispielsweise noch spinnen
und andere tiere wenn ihr möchte dass
ich noch mal einen dritten partie von
aufnehmen wo ich dann irgendwie eine
spinne bin oder so dann schreibt es mir
in die kommentare ich glaube die giraffe
wird sich auch die finnen das bildet
dann das ende vom video